uh I'm going to start with
congratulations on the movie I thought
you guys did such a great job uh but it
really uh and I have a lot of questions
about the movie but I like throwing a
curveball at the beginning so for all
three of you if someone has actually
never seen anything you've done before
what is the first thing you want them
watching and why wow
of any movie of any anything any project
you've worked on wow if the only thing
they watched and I'm not saying it just
because this is what we're talking about
if the only thing they watched was this
story
because it's so well made by Ron Howard
and because on a human level it's about
the best of us
and it's a true story I would I would be
fine if this was the only thing uh I'm
gonna say uh I I would love people to
watch
um
uh
[Music]
yeah loving or yeah
loving maybe I'm a bad genius bad genius
yes bad genius yeah uh so I I thought
that Ron did such a good job well great
job with this because he didn't
hollywoodize this material he just let
let it just play out and between the
script and the way he shot it uh it's so
well done and I'm just curious if you
could talk a little bit about that
aspect that this isn't some spruced up
version of this story it's as it just
felt like a documentary almost
well he's a great Storyteller and he
respects the audience's intelligence you
know it had been another director or
maybe if it had been made 20 years ago
maybe all the Thai characters would have
been speaking English and maybe you
would have had two or three maybe four
leads that would have been the UK divers
and the Australian diver uh and they
would have been the heroes out and have
Heroes what's great about this story
which reflects what the real story was
about is there were no lead actors
everybody was a supporting actor and not
just the divers but hundreds thousands
of people of all nationalities you know
all kinds of cultures
um who pulled together
in a massive Act of volunteerism that's
what's amazing about it and he reflects
that and and the way he layered the
story the fact that there's so much ties
spoken subtitled
um
the fact that he's it's not a visual
effects movie per se it's it's really us
underwater diving
um the things we do the things you see
being done we really had to do or
simulate
um all of that makes it it felt like it
was a big production
but
it felt like a big huge independent
movie because of the that spirit in
which it was made you know the way that
he approached language culture
so you know this big cast I mean yeah
and his his marriage was always to legis
strive for the truth you know when it
came to particularly trying to bring his
own uh you know American Self to
understanding Thai culture and deputies
deputizing members of the cast to teach
him better about how to to render a
moment but always reaching out for what
what really happened and it's a movie
that's so full of characters full of
moments a movie full of moments that is
trying to be devoid of movie moments if
that makes any sense
cliche lines and moments yeah you can
just say I'm scrubbing things away that
were either culturally inappropriate
um you know specifically not true to the
event but trying to distill say for
example one of my favorite characters is
the main mother yeah is distill the
essence of the parents into one
identifiable particular character within
that group and you know because you know
to trying to distill this incredible
story of thousands of you know selfless
volunteers
into a movie I think was one of the
great feats and challenges for Ron yeah
and uh for me I'm gonna I'm gonna answer
in like the Thai aspect the high aspect
to like you know
the Thai aspect about the culture the
people the the accent and everything uh
I think Ron respect the you know like
the Thai cultures so much and he wants
to
you want every detail to be like
authentic so um he keeps asking and uh
he very open mind he willing to if if I
have an idea and then uh you know like
okay the Thai culture you're gonna do
this gonna say this he opened mind and
that he can change so I'm
I watched this movie like a third stop
the first time and um and I
can't say that Thai culture is very
authentic and um yeah uh so I heard Vigo
that you were instrumental in having I
guess originally it wasn't going to be
you guys doing a lot of the scuba scenes
or they weren't sure they could fit it
in Ron was explaining to me that you
were instrumental in the actors doing
the scuba you know going under the water
can you sort of talk about why it was so
important to you that you actually in in
the rest of the cast performed these
scenes of knowing that you know it's a
tough stuff it's tough to do stuff like
that well we were all going to be in the
water it was just it wasn't just part of
it was probably just skill set safety
you know probably producers production
company was saying I don't know if we
should let the actors do all this stuff
but it was also just scheduling I mean
yes it's a big movie but it was probably
half the budget and half the shooting
time that normally a big production like
this would have so they were shooting
with three cameras all the time and it
was like go go and working weekends and
all that and it was just logistically
how will we have time to have you be on
the main unit doing all this stuff on
land and then doing the stuff
in the water all of it you know so they
had doubles for us to do this stuff but
then
the argument was not just like our egos
as actors the argument we all wanted to
do that because it would help Ron see us
up close but also we were watching very
carefully for our own safety but to get
our characters right how the type of
swimming they were doing these cave
divers a very particular kind of diving
and we were imitating them
well enough that Rick Stanton the
technical advisor and Jason and some of
the others the stunt coordinator from
Australia they were saying yeah these
guys are looking like the real guys and
if you can use them if there's a way to
schedule it it would be a plus if
they're willing to do it and all the
actors we kind of decided yeah we could
and so we just said whatever it takes so
we went over time we would look long you
know 12-hour Saturdays when everybody
else was off
and be in the water just to get all
those shots for run and you have to
shoot a lot more than what you're
actually going to use I mean we were so
many hours of footage that wasn't used
and it was just it wasn't like oh me me
the actors want to be on camera it was
no so that it so that the audience would
feel like they were in the water and it
was them it wasn't like they took the
actors heads and
VFX they didn't have the budget to do
that anyway probably and put them on
other divers it was so that consistently
you could tell it's the same body
language it's these guys somebody goes
by and looks up at near where Cameron
you're like oh wow that's that's Joel
that's really him doing that he's got
that kid you know I mean that kind of
stuff it's invaluable for for Ron so the
fact that they were able to trust us and
fit it in schedule wise was a plus like
I can tell you if somebody watches way
too many movies I can tell when it's not
the actors and when I was watching it
yesterday I was like oh wait they really
did this it looks great you know for all
three of you it's probably gonna be my
last question but I love learning about
like the behind the scenes and the
making of a movie what are like maybe
some surprising things that soon to be
fans of this movie might not know about
the actual making of it I mean I know uh
that you know the Topography of a lot of
the uh
the caves that we're working in is like
very you know close to real in terms of
the width and dimensions of some of the
caves you know like I I don't want to
burst the mystery of it and it still
made it feel incredibly dangerous but
you know we're diving in these
elaborately built caves on sound stages
and I think you can watch like a study
of it online about how it was
constructed and and US training in there
that stuff blew my mind I've never sort
of been involved in any kind of
underwater stuff before but I've seen
sets that are tanks just a designer the
design of it was extraordinary we had uh
we've spent so much time in the water
that when it came time to lunch I mean
just to get all your gear off and then
your wetsuit and go by the time you sit
down and have lunch and they're saying
okay back in the water so we would be
handed we were sitting in the water
eating our food it's not a very colon
Colin ordered us Burgers one day in the
in chamber five I think it was and we're
all just floating around in the water
just eating these Incredibles
yeah we spent a lot of time we were I
mean your skin would be so yeah pruned
up by the end of the day and you it's
not just a physical thing and the sort
of your body temperature is gradually
dropping throughout the day
but mentally you're trying to stay
focused so that you know nothing goes
wrong
um and that you do the tasks that you're
supposed to do you have to mentally
spend so much energy I remember just
getting back to the hotel each day and
the first couple days I was like oh I'm
in front of the ocean I'm gonna go for a
swim after work and it's like after a
few days I was like forget about it I
want to eat
a really good dinner and then I'm gonna
pass out because we I mean it was
exhausting it wasn't just physical
though it was mentally you were just
because the focus was there wanting to
get it right
and wanting to survive yeah I just want
to say congrats on the movie and I
thought you guys did such a great job
and thank you for your time thank you
thank you thank you very much